lots of concern being expressed by world
leaders at what we saw unfold in
washington dc
on wednesday from here in berlin we've
heard from chancellor angela merkel
saying she's saddened
by those scenes also foreign minister
heiko mas
saying that this showed that
inflammatory language
resulted in violent scenes saying that
we've
seen a similar thing take place months
ago on the steps of the reichstag here
in berlin now we've seen things go even
further
in the capital building in washington in
fact the bundestag here in germany has
uh said that they're going to increase
security
around uh the reichstag building where
the bundestag
sits in following what happened on
wednesday in washington d.c
now u.s allies around the world have
been
expressing their shock their concern and
a hope
that this doesn't fundamentally damage
america's democracy
we all saw yesterday the unsettling
pictures of the storming of the u.s
congress
these pictures made me angry and also
sad
i regret that since november president
trump has failed to acknowledge his
defeat
and that includes yesterday in the eyes
of the world american democracy appears
under siege
this is an unseen assault on u.s
democracy its institutions
and the rule of law disgraceful scenes
in u.s congress
the united states stands for democracy
around the world and it is now vital
that there should
be a peaceful and orderly transfer of
power we've just seen
you know confidence in democracy being
shattered quite frankly and there's no
justification
for the level of violence full stop
rioters
storming one of the seats of power
saying that they want to carry out a
revolution isn't scenes that we
usually expect to see from the united
states in fact we've heard from
uh politicians in russia who've said
that this
whole thing casts doubt over the us's
position that it's put itself in of
uh bringer of democracy to the world
saying it's well that
usually in these situations it's the
united states that would be
backing those doing the storming of
parliament building certainly that's
what
they've seen in the past when it comes
to reaction from
iran the message coming out of tehran is
there's only one person to blame for
wednesday
what we saw last night and today in
america demonstrates the failure of
western democracy and reveals how
fragile and weak his foundation
is we saw what calamities a populist has
imposed upon his own country over the
past four years
he's blemished the dignity and
reputation of his country
there's also been response from china
where the foreign ministry has put out a
warning on its website the chinese
citizens
in the dc area telling them to
strengthen precautions
that they're taking due to the mass
demonstration that took place
on wednesday um also chinese social
media has been drawing a lot of
comparisons to what we saw
at the capitol building to what we saw
in the arab spring colour revolutions
and in anti-government demonstrations in
hong kong as well a lot of shock being
expressed openly by world
leaders a lot of people wondering what
comes next for the united states
you